ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول مرحبا بكم الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات
تؤكد اجا ستعلن في نفس يوم التصويت رئيسها
احمد ينار قال ان الاستعدادات اليوم
الاقتراع قد اكتملت وان الهيئه اتخذت كافه
التدابير للحفاظ على سلامه سير العمليه
وفي مناطق الزلزال سيصوت الاتراك داخل
كرفانات انشات خصيصا في حدائق المدارس
المتضرره من الكارثه
الرئاسه الروسيه ترفض الاتهامات التي
وجهها كمال موسكو بالتدخل في الانتخابات
المرتقبه وذلك بعد اتهام المرشح الرئاسي
عن تحالف الشعب المعارض لها بالوقوف وراء
فيديو يشوه سمعه مرشحي الرئاسه الرئيس
اردوغان ينتقد تصريحات زعماء المعارضه
بشان الترحيل اللاجئين السوريين الى
بلادهم في حال تولت السلطه في البلاد
ويؤكد خلال لقاء مع الشباب في القصر
الرئاسي انه لا يؤيد هذه الدعوات ووصفها
بالظالمه تعليقا على انسحاب محرم انجي من
السباق الانتخابي رئيس حزب الرفاه من جديد
فاتح اربكان يقول ان هناك مكيده ومؤامره
تقف خلف هذا القرار وان جزءا كبيرا من
كتله الانجي لن تشارك في الانتخابات بينما
سيصوت جزء منها للرئيس اردوغان وجزء اخر
لكمال اوغلو الى اللقاء